la communauté internationale se mobilise
pour aider le nigeria retrouver les 223
fille adolescente kidnappé il ya près
d'un mois
elles ont été enlevées je vous le rappel
par le groupe islamiste boko haram qui
s'opposent à l'éducation des filles et
souhaite instaurer un état islamiste au
nigeria dans le nord du nigeria se fit
langlois est avec moi on va en parler
après analyse et sophie on va essayer
d'expliquer ce qui est difficile à
expliquer cette horreur mais d'abord
contexte parce que c'est une histoire
qui se développe avec les 8,9 après
l'incompréhension et l'indignation c'est
maintenant l'heure de la mobilisation
le canada la france et les états unis
sont tous très âgés rim médiatement pour
aider le nigeria a retrouvé les
adolescentes kidnappé à la mi-avril les
alliés fourniront des équipes techniques
des spécialistes des militaires et des
équipements doit gérer ramener ses
enfants à leurs parents dit angelina
jolie ambassadrice de bonne volonté pour
le nul
les coupables ne doivent pas rester
impunis les adolescentes ont été
kidnappés par le groupe islamiste boko
haram dans leur école et ce n'est pas
par hasard
le groupe est farouchement opposé à
l'éducation des filles leur leader a
déclaré lundi que les otages allaient
être mariées de force ou vendus comme
esclaves
après avoir été accusé d'immobilisme la
police nigériane a promis aujourd'hui
qu'une récompense de 300 mille dollars
pour toute information permettant de les
retrouver mais il est peut-être déjà
trop tard et puis ne serez sans doute
plus dans la journée font de plus au
nigeria il est fort probable plutôt que
certaines d'entre elles voire la plupart
des lycéennes et été amené au cameroun
et au niger voisin
les deux pays qui font souvent aussi
fins de base arrière pour les finalistes
il faudra plus que la colère de la
communauté internationale pourraient
timide et le groupe terroriste
les membres de boko haram ont kidnappé
huit autres écolière hier en plus de
raser
village complet dans le nord du pays où
au moins 300 personnes ont été
massacrées toujours au nom de la
création d'un état islamique au nigeria
ici lille villeneuve radio canada
montréal sophie bonsoir à vous on va
parler de boko haram ont aussi
d'expliquer un peu ce qu'ils veulent et
c'est mais d'abord on voit ci suit le
nigeria si vous le voulez bien on a des
préparé des cartes c'est le pays
africain le plus populeux actuellement
en plein coeur de l'afrique c'est un
très grand pays 177 millions d'habitants
c'est aussi la première économie
africaine ces tissus très récemment
devant l'afrique du sud principalement
en vendant son pétrole aux américains
surtout bon et on voit dans il y avait
une partie mer si eric tu vous pouvez
remettre la carte dont le voit ici il ya
le nord du nigeria où les groupes
islamistes comme boko haram voudrais si
tu es un état islamiste pur dur charia
etc
boko haram ça signifie l'éducation
occidentale est un péché donc c'est une
secte islam et islamisme qui veut
imposer par la force un islam très dur
ils ont d'ailleurs déjà obtenu
l'instauration de la charia dans 9 des
états du nord vous le savez le nord est
dominé par les musulmans ont fait les
musulmans sont plus nombreux dans le
nord est malgré cette richesse qui est
lent au nigeria on disait première
économie du continent c'est un pays donc
qui a des richesses
68% des nigérians sont toujours très
pauvre et c'est particulièrement vrai au
nord du pays les musulmans sont parmi
les plus pauvres et vous le savez une
population pauvre c'est toujours un
terreau très fertile pour un groupe
terroriste qui recrute parmi ces jeunes
désoeuvrés et ils se sont encore plus
radicalisés ils ont toujours été violent
mais encore plus depuis un an depuis que
le gouvernement nigérien a décrété
l'état d'urgence dans trois états du
nord qui est le fief de boko haram et en
réplique à cette offensive militaire
ils ont commencé à multiplier les
attaques presque à tous les jours il ya
même eu aujourd'hui la nouvelle d'un
nouveau massacre qui s'est déroulée
lundi
dans l'état de borno 200 à 300 dans la
joie massacre et borno c'est le même
état où ont été kidnappés les 276 jeune
étudiante dont 223 sont toujours
détenues par boko haram
vous dites pays riches donc des revenus
importants qui vécut qui viennent de la
vente du pétrole
or le gouvernement du nigeria semble
menotté semble ne pas parce que ces
jeunes filles l'oeuvre avant qu'il
quitte le pays j'imagine ça laisse des
traces également on n'a plus rien faire
que vous dites menotté la population
nigériane a plutôt l'impression que son
gouvernement n'a pas voulu déployer les
moyens nécessaires pour aller chercher
ses filles
écoutez une semaine après le kidnapping
les parents étaient tellement désespérés
de voir où en fait d'avoir l'impression
que leur gouvernement ne faisait pas
grand chose qu'ils ont eux même imaginé
organisé des battues et des opérations
de recherches pour aller trouver leur
fait et devant ce silence la population
c'est vraiment un digg et est descendu
dans la rue a forcé le gouverneur le
président nigérian dimanche dimanche et
les réseaux sociaux également parce
qu'imaginez 223 fillette enlevée en
europe où partout ce serait la grosse
histoire 24 heures sur 24 les maires ont
dit des groupes de femmes ont organisé
ces manifestations forçant le
gouvernement à sortir de son silence
après deux semaines le président est
sorti dimanche pour ce qu'il fait et en
santé alors qu'il ne sait pas où elles
sont et pourtant c'est des milliards que
ce gouvernement-là consacre à sa
sécurité
le tiers du budget de l'état nigérian
est consacrée à la sécurité
une partie de cet argent là vient des
états unis
ils ont donc les moyens mais le nord a
toujours eu l'impression qu'ils étaient
les gens au nord qu'ils étaient négligés
par le sud et ont l'impression d'en
avoir une autre preuve
expliquez moi ce fut là les américains
en faire depuis quelques jours le raid
on a vu le premier ministre britannique
même si aujourd'hui des français bon
qu'est ce que la communauté tant elle
peut faire écouter des groupes de femmes
nigérianes ont réussi un coup de maître
en métal ring bakar glosent sur twitter
ces derniers jours ça a vraiment fait
tâche d'huile sur la planète il ya mais
michelle obama qui s'était près-midi
a mis une photo d'elle-même avec une
pancarte bring bagarre glosent sur
twitter et qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
il est tard tout le monde dit qu'il est
très tard si le jour même ou dans les
jours qui ont suivi on avait mis des
outils de géolocalisation des satellites
qui peuvent intercepter des
conversations cellulaire alors qu'on
déplaçait imaginer 276 filles dans les
camions qui se déplace ou dans les
premiers jours c'est assez facilement
repérables maintenant si on les a
dispersés et selon les renseignements
américains
il serait effectivement maintenant
dispersés dans plusieurs caches dans les
pays voisins
c'est beaucoup plus difficile ça prend
les militaires nigérians qui connaissent
le terrain ils peuvent être aidés mais
bon au moins maintenant les familles de
ces faits là ne se sentent plus seuls
dans leur combat la planète entière a
l'air d'être derrière ce fut l'endroit
merci infiniment on va suivre évidemment
tout ça merci je vous en prie l'arrêt